it spiraled so far out of control that
my mum and dad finally stepped in and
said you need to get help
[Music]
i'm alex i'm 23 and the relationship
with my body was unhealthy for most of
my life
[Music]
i traced it all the way back to when i
was about 10 years old my parents got
divorced and
the next six months after that i began
to comfort eat and fill that void and
naturally i did start to put on a little
bit of body fat
kids being kids were very harsh and did
start bullying me
i started to restrict my food and
started to exercise every opportunity
that i possibly could at the age of 11.
i lost weight very quickly and that's
when the obsession started spiraling out
of control i jumped on the internet and
whatever unreliable
direct culture fuel information i found
that's what drove me to be restricted
i remember one afternoon my mum pulled
me out of school
took me to the doctor not far away and
he had just received recent blood test
results that i got done previously and
the doctor looked me in the eye and
told me that i had about two days to
live
and said mum's taking you to hospital
and he said you need to go right now you
can't go home you can't go back to
school you go into emergency
i i questioned at the time um what have
i done to myself
and i understand now that i didn't do
anything to myself the eating disorder
did
but i it really really slapped me across
the face that i had nearly died
[Music]
when i was at the depths of my my
anorexia nervosa i constantly saw
someone that was too large
too fat
needed to lose more body fat
in later high school when i was allowed
to actually start going to the gym and
lifting weights
that's when i started to take a turn
[Music]
the eating disorder was no longer about
being lean it was more about
starting to become obsessed with being
as muscular as i possibly could
i am an extremely anxious person
i have
deep persistent
sensations or experiences of anxiety on
a day-to-day basis
combine all of these things with low
self-esteem
and sprinkle in some perfectionist
traits it's a recipe for
an eating disorder
i understood i needed to see a
psychologist and i started seeing one
who started helping me address my
anxiety and depressive symptoms
which alongside self-help books
genuinely changed my life
the way i perceived the world the way i
perceived myself the way i
actually walked about on a day-to-day
basis and approached life
through my anxious brain
it genuinely helped me
control my anxiety better
i can say nowadays that i'm fully
recovered from my eating disorder
i no longer have distressing thoughts or
behaviors around my eating
with my body image side of things i am
almost there
i don't want to say that i'm fully
recovered from it but i can safely say
that those thoughts no longer get in the
way of my day
i've come to a place where i've accepted
my body for the way that it looks and
the way that it is
just because i look a certain way it
doesn't mean that that is my identity
and i no longer
feel as if i have to
present as a certain physique to
somebody to be alex to be the person
that i want to be
[Music]
there's anything we've spoken about on
this episode that has triggered you
eating disorder or body image wise
please see the links below